Brook is in Washington hey Brooke what's
up
hi mr. Ramsey I I'm in two hundred and
twelve thousand dollars of student loan
debt it's only that I have wow your
doctor or a lawyer I went to law school
I am going to take the bar in July yay
why are you in don't usually why took it
twice already
oh okay har I graduated 2017 it's there
I failed twice by six points both times
so my question is half of that debt is
already with creditors half of that that
is about to be defaulted on what do I do
with the debt that's already with the
creditors and how do I I don't even know
where to start to kinda even start
paying it off and if I can with the
creditors because you know they want
large lump sum yeah the collectors yeah
now these are all federal student loans
no a lot of them are private hmm so
higher interest rates correct and what
are you doing for a living I'm walking
dogs I'm trying to find a job I'm trying
to get a bigger shovel but a lot of the
jobs that I'm qualified for check your
credit and because my credit is not that
great I don't move forward the process
so I'm working two jobs looking for a
third what kind of a job trying to get
the check sure credit I was I got an
interview for a HIPAA compliance for the
federal government and they said that
they'd rather me have credit card debt
then student loan debt because I would
be in violation of public trust with
student loan debt yeah which you know
makes a lot of sense they're the ones
that make the freaking student loans
right federal government is so backward
it's just ridiculous
unbelievable I know okay so but you're
in default either way so you don't
really qualify for stuff where they're
doing a security check or a HIPPA check
regardless of what you're into fault on
so what else could you do though I mean
you got a degree in what other than
jurisprudence uh psychology okay and so
you were just trying to use the law
background with the feds well I was just
trying to get a good-paying job so I
could start chipping away at this bet at
this point I don't care what I do I just
want to be debt-free you only get that I
have but I mean I would think you could
go to work with someone almost in a
paralegal capacity applied for paralegal
positions what they say you know we want
someone here that's going to be five
years you're taking the bar you want to
be an attorney we all need someone with
life ambition that's true that's fair
okay all right yeah so anyway all right
really what amounts to is is you're
making survival money until you pass the
bar they're probably not getting any
money agreed okay so it doesn't really
matter all you do just say I can't pay
you or any money what are they gonna do
don't take one of the dogs you're
walking I mean there's nothing they can
do well they what my mom is my concern
or in one of the world you take her
house I'm in her card I don't know
anything but my mom does so I just even
if I do get a bigger shovel is there
anything I can do with yeah once you
once you get your bar passed and you
land a good law job you can begin to
attack this because you've got some
income but you're gonna have to have
some income to attack this with you
can't attack it with a wish right right
right and so you know I don't think
they're probably going to do a lot of
stuff they're threatening to your mom as
quick as they're acting like they're
just trying to jack everybody's emotions
up which they're really good at but I
think you know I think any money you can
make to make sure you get survival done
and then beyond that that you can start
to address some of the more aggressive
ones with some kind of a payment plan
until you pass the bar and until you get
there anything you can do to just kind
of stiff arm them and hold them off but
the bottom line is we need to pay two
hundred twenty thousand bucks off right
and in order to do that we need to make
a hundred right so we got past the bar
you know and so then you you continue to
live on nothing and you start throwing
you start throwing 50 75 thousand
dollars at this thing
a year or more it's going to go away the
pressure is going to go away first and
then the deaths going to start to go
away it'll melt away because you know
but it is just an arithmetic thing that
you don't you simply do not have you
have a desire to pay it you just don't
any money right right and so the way to
saw the the shortest path out in
discussing this with you I think to
solving that is is passing the bar and
you're not eligible to sit for it again
until July correct
I missed the February deadline because
it costs money to take the bar okay well
this is a priority not only sitting for
but passing the bar is a priority
because it solves not just the hits the
goal of why you did all of this but then
also it solves the arithmetic problem
that we've got here so that's that's the
sole focus of everything is survival and
passing the bar between now and July
that's what I would do and so but I
don't I don't have any expectation that
you're gonna make any big headway until
you get some income coming in and I
don't think you're gonna have a big
income coming in until you get this done
it doesn't sound to me like so if
there's something you can take with your
doctor there's burdens your fact that
you passed the law or passed law school
and goal and something somewhere the
page 100 grant have at it I'm I'm up for
that not mad about it but you're much
more likely if you are to create an
income if you pass the thing so a good
question thank you for joining us